Uy, que salido.
Hola, hola a todos.
A ver, lo que os quería comentar es que
ayer eh creé una una cuenta de Gemik.
Aparte, bueno, los que los que venís de
los que estáis en segundo y estáis
haciendo esta asignatura de primero,
¿vale? Hm. Ya tenéis activado la
plataforma. mirarlo a ver si a ver si
podéis entrar en la en la aplicación.
¿Vale? Y otro punto es que tenemos ayer
cre una cuenta de drive, ¿vale? Y ahí
vamos a ir subiendo ejercicios no
evaluables. Los evaluables siempre los
haremos en
siempre los haremos en la en la
plataforma de de
los no evaluables sí que los podemos o
bien hacerlos para para compartirlos en
clase y y corregirlos en clase,
¿vale? El caso es que no son evaluables
y no importa. O sea, si os he compartido
a todos una carpeta. A ver, esperad,
esperad y vemos la disposición de las
carpetas.
Vale, sería esto. Vale.
Vale. En nuestro caso sería redes
locales, ¿vale?
Y aquí en esta carpeta, o sea, aquí
tenéis permisos de lectura, ¿vale? Para
todas las carpetas que que hay. Hola.
Para todas las carpetas que hay tenéis
permisos de lectura, excepto para esta
de entregas evaluables,
que ahí tenéis permiso de de edición,
¿vale?
Y como veo ya habéis ido entregando
cosillas. Vale, genial.
Vale, Eduardo ya ha ido entregando
cosas.
Vale,
vale. Pues eso, importante que pongáis
el nombre de de en el ejercicio, ¿vale?
O sea, que en un principio sí que se ve
el propietario quién ha sido, pero como
tenéis permiso de edición sobre
cualquier documento, imagínate que entra
un, o sea, no os lo hagáis a vosotros,
por Dios. Entra un compañero y se pone a
editar el archivo de otro.
Vale, porque este en este caso sería,
vale, somos todos, todos podemos editar
los archivos de todos. Entonces, a ver,
un poco de sentido común aquí
con esto. Es básicamente por no crear
una carpeta para cada uno. Y si me
enviáis, mira, como el caso de Eduardo
que ha enviado 1 2 3 cu 5, si enviáis
cinco ejercicios, meterlos dentro de un
zip, o sea, los comprimís y le ponéis
vuestro nombre,
¿vale? O sea, una buena, a ver, una
buena manera de entregar, o sea, más que
nada es para mí, eh, para luego, porque
claro, yo
luego si aquí tengo 50 ejercicios, que
todos se llaman ejercicio uno, ejercicio
uno, tal, ostras, vale, que sí que, o
sea, prefiero ver sí que ha puesto deu
así en primera, o sea, no está mal,
¿vale? lo ha tenido en cuenta, pero
prefiero que que A ver, espera, espera
que saco el blog de notas y lo y os lo
pongo. La contraseña del wifi de aquí,
¿tú te la sabes o
no? Te la digo, te la digo ahora. Es la
misma de ayer, ¿eh? Que es la wifi.
No te conectaste ayer al wifi.
No, es que conectó al móvil. Ah, vale,
vale, vale,
vale. Pues ahora te lo digo.
la foto
d
ahí no lo vas a ver bien porque cogido
todo el
[Música]
vale
lo ves bien se ve
H
y
vale, estamos, o sea, configuración para
para enviar archivos. Esto lo pondré de
alguna manera en en un archivo de texto,
o sea, nombre, eh, yo que sé, nombre,
¿vale?
apellidos
y ejercicio,
¿vale? El nombre del ejercicio, el
nombre, los apellidos y el y el y el
ejercicio que estáis haciendo. Ya está.
Y luego la extensión por la que sea. Si
es un archivo comprimido, pues punto c
punto RAR. Si es eh de paquet tracer,
pues PKT, PDF, PDF, pero siempre
utilizar esta esta nomenclatura, ¿vale?
Más que nada por el pifost, tío, se
puede formar aquí en la carpeta.
Vale, a ver.
Vale, tenéis dos dos
entregas, dos ejercicios no evaluables
que los tenéis tanto aquí como
replicados en la
en la aplicación
de TAME, en la plataforma. A ver,
estamos aquí, ¿vale? Tendríais este el
uno
ejercicio 1 unidad 1 y ejercicio 1.1
unidad 1. ¿Vale? Pues eso, ir
haciéndolos y si queráis los corregimos
también en si queréis hacerlos.
Bueno, claro, vamos a dar un poquito de
clase y luego si queréis dejamos un
espacio para ir haciendo alguno de ellos
los corregibles también.
A ver. ¿Qué material tengo aquí? Esto ya
ayer nos quedamos
en redes.
Vamos a ver,
estábamos en unidad uno. Tenemos los
ejercicios de Cisco que hicisteis hasta
el hicisteis hasta el tres,
¿cierto? No. Y el tres lo hicisteis ya.
Y luego tenemos el cuatro, ¿vale? El
cuatro ni siquiera lo he subido al al y
el cuatro sí que lo podríamos lo podría
Vale, pues lo voy a subir a plataforma
y luego tenemos una práctica que sería
el cinco,
un router y con un switch, ¿vale? Aunque
no os suene un poco a marciano todo esto
de router, switch o qué.
No,
no. A todos.
Bueno, vamos a seguir con el temario. O
sea, yo es que quiero que que os
familiarizáis con el software de Fispa,
¿vale? porque lo vamos a utilizar
bastante.
Vale, entonces voy a entrar aquí en la
en la plataforma y vale
redes locales,
redes locales.
Vale,
para que os familiaricéis con la
plataforma también
los ejercicios en vuestra página de
inicio. Puedes entrar, Álvaro, a la
plataforma de
Vale.
Si entráis en vuestro usuario, veréis
que
a mano derecha aparece un módulo en el
que os pone las actividades que están
más recientes de entrega, ¿vale? O sea,
las que están más próximas a su entrega.
O sea, es como un panel de recordatorios
de qué son qué ejercicios tenéis que que
ir entregando.
Vale, ayer estábamos con caracterización
de redes locales, ¿no?
Allá estamos con esto.
Hm.
Y llegamos hasta hasta aquí. De hecho,
los ejercicios que hay, uno de ellos
tiene que ver con con todo esto,
¿vale? Y sí, todo esto lo hemos visto,
porque además no me he puesto
marcas aquí,
¿no? Porque ayer
y estuvimos mirando.
Me sale que solamente soy el lector.
¿Cómo? ¿Cómo
me sale que soy el lector?
¿Qué eres? ¿Qué? Lector. Héctor,
no. Lector.
Ah, lector.
No me deja editar.
Vale, claro. Es que no no te tienen que
dejar editar.
O sea, sí que te dejará subir
actividades, ¿no? O sea, por ejemplo, si
te si te vas a la actividades
evaluables,
ahí sí que te dejará te de ahí tendrás
un espacio para subir el archivo.
Vale. A ver,
redes,
unidad uno y unidad uno resumen, ¿vale?
Y y no estuvimos haciendo más realmente,
¿vale? Entonces pasaríamos ahora a la
unidad dos, ¿no?
Entiendo. Y ahora también nos pasaría
esto,
¿vale?
Estuvimos viendo arquitectura de una
red, familias de protocolos usuales. Sí,
esto sí que lo estuvimos viendo
ayer, ¿no? Porque ayer estuvimos mirando
el packet tracer y todo esto. Vale, los
el modelo Osis.
Vale, vale, vale,
vale. Genial, genial.
Vale, entonces vamos con la
dos,
¿vale? El cableado de red.
Vale, el cableado red. Eh, fuera del del
ámbito doméstico, la instalación de un
sistema de cableado para una corporación
exige la realización de un proyecto en
el que han de tenerse en cuenta los
recursos disponibles, procedimientos,
calendarios de ejecución, costes,
documentación, etcétera. ¿Vale? El
proyecto de instalación h consiste en la
ejecución ordenada según las directrices
del proyecto de instalación de un
conjunto de tareas que revierten en
proporcional servicio que necesita el
cliente que solicitó la instalación.
Algunas de estas tareas se pueden
superponer en el tiempo y habrá que
tener esto en cuenta al confeccionar el
calendario de instalación.
Vale, describimos algunas de estas
tareas. Instalación de tomas de
corrente. Super importante esto. Luego
si no te toca ir con regletas por todos
los sitios y
y asalto de mata un poco, o sea,
planifica siempre planifica. Vale, esta
tarea suele realizarla en un
electricista, pero desde el punto de
vista del proyecto debemos asegurarnos
que hay suficientes tomas de corriente.
¿Por qué? Porque en un RAC, a ver,
sabéis lo que es un RAC, ¿no? Es un
armario donde vamos a instalar los
diferentes compon cuando entráis por los
que venís aquí, cuando entráis eh, en la
pecera esta que está en el aula al lado,
hay un,
bueno, vosotros que venís del del curso
entero montado, claro, evidentemente,
eh, pero pues no hay otros otros alumnos
que igual no lo han igual no lo han
tocado, ¿vale?
Entonces, aquí hay muchísimos, bueno,
muchísimos, yo que sé, a lo mejor hay 15
dispositivos que que conectar, ¿vale?
Entonces ahí tenemos que tener en cuenta
este tipo de
eso solo en es solo en el RAC, ¿vale?
O sea, que potencia también que, hombre,
generalmente, a ver, son muchas son
cosas a tener en cuenta, vamos a
numerarlas. instalación de las tomas de
corriente, porque no solo está el RAC,
hay los diferentes dispositivos también
que estén luego en la red.
¿Vale? Imaginad que ponemos un punto
wifi en mitad de una oficina y lo
ponemos en el techo. O sea, tenemos que
tener en cuenta que la línea de
electricidad va a pasar por ahí porque
ese punto wifi tiene que estar
alimentado.
¿Vale? Esta tarea suele realizarlo en
electricista, pero desde el punto de
vista del proyecto debemos asegurarnos
de que hay suficientes tomas de
corriente para alimentar todos los
equipos de comunicaciones.
Punto wifi en el techo, por ejemplo. O
sea, ¿de dónde cogeríamos la luz?
¿Se os ocurre
la toma de corriente?
Pero, ¿qué toma de corriente? porque
estamos en el techo,
una tapa de registro, o sea, las típicas
tapas de registro que hay en por las
paredes, ¿vale? Pues de ahí podríamos
llevar una canaleta, a lo mejor tenemos
que poner 1 metro de canaleta de de
cable de cable eléctrico y llevarle y
llevarle alimentación, ¿no? O incluso en
el falso techo, a lo mejor levantando el
falso techo, tenemos ahí una caja de
registro con
de corriente, ¿vale? Y ahí podemos
conectar,
¿vale? Instalación de rosetas y jacks.
Es la instalación de los puntos de red
finales desde los que se conectan desde
los que se conectarán los equipos de
comunicaciones, sirviéndose de
latiguillos. Sirviéndose de latiguillos.
¿Vale? La mayor parte de estas
conexiones residirán en canaletas o en
armarios de cableado.
Ya. Esto de aquí, eh, Jorge,
estamos hablando de esto de aquí, esta
canaleta, ¿ves? que tienen las rosetas
con la red,
¿vale? Y ahí también, bueno, ahí está un
poco más chapucero porque no está
tapada, pero
y si nos vamos a la, bueno, al aula que
estuvimos ayer en la aula 13, pues
también aparece, ¿no? Creo que estaban
todas las mesas estaban unidas por una
pletina
y estaban por la parte de la parte de
Sí.
En el aula dos, por ejemplo, donde se
hizo la presentación abajo, ¿te
acuerdas? Ahí estaban también todas las
toda la fila de mesas una canaleta, por
ejemplo.
Vale, tendido de los cables. Se trata de
medir la distancia que debe recorrer
cada cable y añadirle una longitud
prudente que nos permita trabajar
cómodamente
con él antes de cortarlo. ¿Vale? Esto es
esto es super importante. O sea,
imagínate que tiras 25 m de cable
y de repente,
claro, ¿cómo cómo os lo digo? Así sin
por zoom. De repente dejas eh dejas 10
cm solo para conexión, ¿vale? Y se te
queda corto. Evidentemente deja más. O
sea, ya que has tirado 25 m, deja un
trozo más, ¿vale? Porque así tendrás
maniobra, porque imagínate que el
clipado no lo haces como toca, pues
entonces te va a tocar cortar y volverlo
a y volverlo a poner. O sea, ahí sijas
muy poquito espacio,
estás ahí en extremis, ¿vale? Con el a
la hora de montar un cable.
O sea, aquí ser generoso con eso que
luego al final un metro de cable es un
céntimo,
¿vale? Eh, conectorización de los cables
en los patch panels y en las rosetas
utilizando las herramientas de crimpado
apropiadas. A esto se denomina, bueno,
cross connect, ¿vale? Probado de los
cables instalados. Cada cable construido
y conectorizado debe ser inmediatamente
probado para asegurarse de que cumplirá
correctamente su función. Hombre, esto
es importante también.
Imaginaos que estamos configurando un
servidor con un con un cliente, estamos
haciendo las pruebas, estamos poniendo
todo perfecto,
todos los parámetros perfectos, tal, y
de repente aquello no conecta, o sea,
vale, o sea, probemos esos cables antes,
¿no? Porque luego nos va a ser un
problema, ¿eh? que sí que al final vamos
a dar con la solución, pero pero nos va
nos va a llevar un poquito de quebradero
de cabeza,
¿vale? Y este es, yo creo que es el más
importante de todos, el siguiente.
Etiquetado y documentación del cable y
conectores. O sea, yo por lo menos,
Vale, todo cable debe ser etiquetado en
ambos extremos, así como los conectores
de patch panel y rosetas, de modo que
queden identificados
un bueno inequívocamente, ¿vale?
Es importantísimo, o sea, por razones
obvias, porque tú a lo mejor estás en tú
desplegas esa red
en el 2027,
¿vale? Y a los dos al año ya no estás en
ese sitio y va a venir alguien detrás
que va a tener que que
Claro. Entonces, entonces va a ir loco
si no si no etiquetamos bien las cosas.
Vale, es una manera de dejar a
compañeros que vienen detrás, pues el
camino el camino fácil. Lo que os
gustaría encontraros a vosotros,
dejárselo a otros,
¿vale? Porque a ti te gustaría llegar a
un sitio y de repente tenerlo ahí todo
más carito, ¿no? Mira, esto tal, este
está etiquetado, tal. No es que lo digo
porque hay auténticos sapuzos por ahí
haciendo cositas.
Vale, que sí que que en el grado o donde
hayan estudiado sí que posiblemente lo
lleven a rejata tabla eso, pero luego en
el en el ámbito laboral pasan de eso.
Vamos,
eso mal, no lo hagáis.
Vale, instalación de los adaptadores de
red. Gran parte de los equipos
informáticos viene ya con la tarjeta de
red instalada, pero esto no es así
necesariamente, ¿vale? Pues sí,
evidentemente hay o a lo mejor tenéis un
equipo que lo vais a utilizar como
servidor y solo trae una tarjeta de red,
pero vosotros queréis dos, ¿no? Para
hacer una para conectar una LAN
y y luego que tenga acceso a internet
mediante otra, o sea, o le podéis
instalar más.
instalación de los dispositivos. Se se
trata de instalar los concentradores,
conmutadores, puentes y encaminadores.
Algunos de estos dispositivos deben ser
configurados antes de prestar su
servicio, ¿vale? Configuración del
software de red en clientes y servidores
de la red, ¿vale? Eso es evidente
también
sin configuración. Ya lo visteis ayer.
Si en ese ejercicio que hicimos con el
Packet Tracer, si no, o sea, por mucho
que tú pongas los componentes
los unas con PC, crees crees la crees la
red con los cables y tal, si luego no le
si luego no configuras mediante
software, no hay nada que hacer. O sea,
eso no se va
no se va a comunicar. Vale. Vale.
Elementos de la instalación.
La instalación de la red no solo se
compone de cables y conectores. Estos
deben ser fijados en las instalaciones
arquitectónicas de los edificios.
Además, hay que hacerlos, convivir con
lasci con las extracciones de otra
naturaleza que probablemente ya hayan
sido tendidas con anterioridad.
agua, fuerza eléctrica, aire
acondicionado. Generalmente en los
edificios a partir de los años 90,
edificios de vivienda, a partir de sobre
el 95 sí que entró la normativa de crear
una
una zona de registro de canalización de
de
instalaciones,
¿vale? y suelen ir separadas.
Instalación de cable, instalación para
internet,
la instalación eléctrica por otro lado y
la instalación del agua por otro
también. Esto por normativa, pero antes
de esos años os vais a encontrar con
edificios que no tienen absolutamente
nada. Entonces os va a tocar tirar por
la fachada cuando viene el señor Digi a
instalaros el la fibra.
Si vivís en un edificio de de antes de
los 90 que sobre el 90
así creo que que empezó, ¿vale? Si
viviese un edificio anterior a esto,
pues posiblemente le toque tirar cable
por la fachada hasta que os entre en la
en la conexión de vuestra casa. Vale,
vale. Armarios y canaletas en
instalaciones de tipo medio. Por
supuesto, en una empresa esto, o sea, en
un local, una nave industrial o algo
así, pues este estos son problemas
menores, ¿no? En todos los sitios, pero
pero generalmente contamos con más
espacio. Las zonas comunes no existe el
el tema de las zonas comunes que se
puede haber en un edificio de viviendas.
Vale, entonces las canalizaciones en una
empresa suele ser algo bastante más más
sencillo.
Si el departamento de administración se
tiene que desplazar un poquito, pues no
pasa nada. Si hay que hacer un doble
tabique por algún sitio, por lo que sea,
no pasa nada. Si hay que poner una una
regleta por arriba y siempre que cumpla
la normativa,
pues tampoco va a pasar nada. cosas que
no podemos hacer en una zona común, en
un edificio de viviendas, que ahí
tendremos que pedir permiso a la
comunidad, etcétera, etcétera.
Vale. Vale. Armarios y canaletas,
¿vale? Esquema de un armario. Aquí nos
nos
presenta
nos presenta un rack, ¿vale? y con
con los diferentes.
Bueno, no todos tienen monitor, a no
todos se le pone monitor, podemos
acceder remotamente, ¿vale? En
instalación de tipo medio o grande, los
equipos de comunicaciones se instalan
armarios especiales que tienen unas
dimensiones estandarizadas y en los que
es fácil su manipulación y la fijación
de los cables que a ellos se conectan.
Dentro de estos armarios o racks se
instalan bandejas de soporte o pas pan
panel para la conexión de jacks o de
otro tipo de conectores. La anchura de
los racks está normalizada a 19
pulgadas. En la figura siguiente podemos
ver un diagrama ejemplo de uno de estos
armarios,
¿vale?
Ahí tenemos el el este el multiplicador
eléctrico, ¿vale?
Pero, ¿vale? Podemos tirar de esto,
podemos usar esto, podemos también
eh
podemos tener a lo mejor algunos
enchufes también eh fuera, ¿vale? Fuera
del rack y conectar algunos dispositivos
fuera. Eso a lo que me refería antes.
Además, poner multiplicador eléctrico
para poner poner buscar precios
buscar precios de multiplicador
eléctrico para Rena,
porque a veces sí, o sea, está bien, hay
empresas en las que tiran tiran millas,
¿vale? Pero pero en otras a lo mejor te
están diciendo, "Ostras, esto se dispara
un poco."
A ver, depende mucho.
Depende, depende de la cantidad.
24 27.
¿Cómo?
13 24 27.
Pero, pero, ¿cuántos? Claro,
¿cuántos?
Es que los de poco será un poquito, pero
claro, imagínate que tienes conectar que
conectar de 10.
Claro, él 12
de 12 para arriba.
Claro, porque si vas a conectar,
imaginar, mira el site
al panel de, bueno, el panel de
conexiones, el teclado, el monitor,
unidad, es que depende, depende mucho,
¿vale? Pero los que tienen poquito no
son muy son no son caros, ¿vale? Pero
los que los que sí que tienen varias
tomas, eso ya se dispara un poco.
A mí se de 62 € por arriba.
62. Vale, hombre. Pues tampoco los tenía
más claro. Última vez que lo Bueno,
bueno, pero 62 ya pican, ¿eh?
Bueno, la altura de los armarios suele
medirse en
U. Una U es la medida estandarizada de
las bandejas de un rack o armario. Es
laatura de RAC Unit. Equivale a una
altura en armario de 1, bueno, de 1,75
pulgadas.
Vale, la la altura 175 cada unidad,
¿vale?
En Cos se incluyen en las paredes del
RAC tres tornillos de fijación. Por
ejemplo, el armario, la figura anterior
medía 42. Pues nada, 42* 44 por 45.
1,86
1,87
Vale, los fabricantes suelen ajustar sus
equipos para que se puedan ensamblar en
estos armarios ocupando un dos o más o
más unidades de RAC, ¿vale? La mayoría
de los ras se se quean los centros de
procesos de datos tienen una altura de
42 aproximadamente un 1,8.
Vale, pues eso, este en concreto
sería 17. Las canaletas son los
conductos a través de los cuales se
tienden los cables para que queden
recogidos y protegidos convenientemente.
Hay canaletas decorativas de aspecto más
acabado cuya misión es ocultar los
cables y canaletas acanaladas que suelen
instalarse en los falsos techos
o falsos suelos y que son
suficientemente grandes como para llevar
muchos cables. Las canalizaciones de
datos y de fuerzas pueden estar
separadas para evitar interferencias.
¿Vale?
Eh, las canaletas suelen ser lo que
nadie instala,
¿vale? O sea, no es lo importante, pero
vamos que ahí están
a la izquierda, o sea, al final ves el
rack con los cableados por ahí, todo
hecho ahí una una maraña por la parte de
atrás,
¿vale? a la izquierda y arriba van de, o
sea,
os lo digo por la por la experiencia,
¿vale? De
de esto, al final que sí que que está
que es muy, a ver, en un mundo perfecto
sí se utilizarían todos los
todos los elementos estos, pero pero no
suele ser el caso. Acostumbraos a
ponerlos. Claro, si tenéis que hacer un
presupuesto, pues presupuestar todo.
Luego ya vendrá el cliente diciendo,
"Ostras, es que se me sube precio. ¿Qué
podemos ir quitando aquí?" Ah, vale,
pues vamos a quitar, vamos a quitar las
canaletas, que igual que que esta que es
específica, pues me sirve esta otra. O
no le ponemos canaleta porque son 10 cm
o lo que se va a ver el cable. Vale,
pues ese tipo de
ese tipo de cuestiones tenerlas en
cuenta, ¿vale? Suelos y techos técnicos,
¿vale? Las canalizaciones tendidas por
suelos y techos técnicos mejoran la
limpieza de la instalación, haciéndola
además mucho más estética. Existen
rosetas especiales para extraer los
falsos suelos. Tanto, nunca habéis visto
alguna vez eso vosotros que estuvisteis
en primero, por ejemplo, las rosetas
puestas en el suelo.
Creo que sí.
Vale, vale. Pues serían conexiones que
se hacen. A ver, ¿qué se busca en eso?
Pues en una oficina o en un centro
educativo, pues a lo mejor lo que se
busca es la,
o sea, que una la polivalencia de una
sala, ¿vale? O sea, que tú puedas tener
las mesas en diferentes disposiciones.
Con esto lo consigues.
No estás eh a expensas de tener la
roseta cercana, o sea, de tener el
puesto de trabajo cercano a a a una
pared
y sobre todo en espacios diáfanos,
espacios grandes, pues esto es un esto
es una ventaja. Vale.
Vale. Existen rosetas especiales para
extraer de los falsos suelos, tanto
datos como fuerza, pero en el diseño hay
que poner cuidado para que no estorben
el paso y para que queden protegidas con
el fin de evitar su deterioro.
Vale, los cables llegan a los armarios a
través de los falsos suelos justo por
debajo de ellos, lo que ayuda a la
limpieza de la instalación. Los
distintos cables avanzan ordenadamente
normalmente embridados por los vértices
del armario hasta alcanzar la altura a
la que deben ser conectados en algún
dispositivo o o en algún patch panel.
Vale, entiendo que nos habla de
del RACK, ¿vale? Pero yo os os lo
comento en general, ¿vale? O sea, en una
instalación tener esto esto presente,
suelos por los que hayan
los que haya canalizaciones y podéis y
podéis tener esto en una sala diáfana.
Imagínate una sala diáfana de 100 m²,
pues es un de de 10 por 10, ¿vale?
Imagínate con un pilar central o pues
hombre que vas a tener toda la
distribución puesta en las en los
laterales de las paredes, ¿no? O sea, lo
vas a hacer mucho más
mucho más útil los espacios si esas
canalizaciones y das la oportunidad de
ponerlas de ponerlas más centradas, ¿no?
O sea, que que abarquen más más ámbito,
¿vale? la instalación eléctrica y de
aire acondicionado, ¿vale? Es muy
importante que la instalación eléctrica
esté muy bien hecha, ¿vale? Claro,
siempre de no ser así se corren riesgos
importantes, incluso electrocución.
Los problemas eléctricos suelen generar
problemas intermitentes muy difíciles de
diagnosticar y provocan deterioros
importantes en los dispositivos de red.
Todos los dispositivos de red deben
estar conectados a enchufes con tierra.
Las carcasas de estos dispositivos, los
armarios, las canaletas mecánicas,
etcétera, también debe ser conectados a
tierra.
La instalación debe estar a su vez
conectada a tierra del edificio. Por
tanto, habrá que comprobar que el número
de tomas de tierra que posee es
suficiente para lograr una tierra
aceptable. Otro problema importante que
hay que resolver viene originado por los
cortes de corriente o las subidas y
bajadas de tensión. Para ello podemos
utilizar sistemas de alimentación
interrumpida.
¿Vale? ¿Conocéis algún sistema de de
alimentación interrumpida?
Vale, estos serían los, ¿vale?
Los sistemas de alimentación
interrumpidas corrigen todas las
deficiencias de la corriente eléctrica.
Aquí es como a buscar precios de size.
Este sí que es Este es bueno.
Y po.
Vale, pues eso es baratísimo.
Busca un para RCK.
Sí,
€
si pones ahí para RAT te pone 200 € en
uno de PC componentes
en PC componente. A ver cómo es este.
V un size
un size potentillo.
Espera, voy a poner ahí.
Empieza componentes de 500 W.
pico. 800 tal pues de ahí para arriba
910. Vale,
o sea, a ver, aquí tenemos aquí sí que
es es esto. Espera,
un sí vale 500 W. Vale, pues ahí tenemos
una potencia. Aquí en las
especificaciones de ese Sai sí que nos
dirá, ¿vale? Este, a ver, no es lo un
para casa si nos puede costar a lo mejor
200, 300 pavos, que está muy bien. O
sea, eso es perfecto. Al final no es más
que una batería. O sea, dentro que lleva
un lleva una batería, ¿vale? Un software
que gestiona el tema. Eh, para un rack
tenemos que tener algo más algo más
potentillo, ¿vale? Porque son muchos los
componentes que
que está que está manejando. Imagínate
que se nos va la luz, que hay picos de
luz, o sea, de electricidad, me refiero.
Pues ahí tenemos que manejar ya cosas
más más caras. A ver, seis buenos por
1000 y pico, 2000, por ahí va la por ahí
va la cosa.
Este no digo que sea malo, ¿vale? Pero
igual hay uno de 700 700 y pico W.
Este es de 500. Línea interactiva,
o sea, en función de los vatios que nos
que nos presenta y de los A ver,
nivel de ruido. Vale, tenemos que tener
eso también en cuenta. A lo mejor
tenemos compramos un baratuno y tiene un
ruidoco infernal.
que luego nos llama el cliente ahí,
"Oye, ¿qué me has puesto aquí?" No, no,
no es que se va muy bien.
Pues, pues esa todo ese tipo de cosas
hay que tenerlas en cuenta.
Vale,
así una primera búsqueda. A ver.
Es que quería a ver
seis profesionales. Vale, vamos aquí.
300 340 está bien. Pero, ¿cuánto nos
tiene este?
Vale, el armario, por ejemplo, que eso
no hemos hablado de los precios también,
o sea, está sí que estamos mirando,
estamos mirando los diferentes
componentes, pero intento que los que lo
conectéis con la realidad y la realidad
es que sí, que os gustaría diseñar redes
brutales, pero o con o con los
componentes que nos viene la
imaginación, ¿vale?
Pero tenemos que tener en cuenta también
que posiblemente nos estén pidiendo un
presupuesto y ese presupuesto tenemos
que manejarlo y que y que nos lo acepten
también. Cuanto más piezas caras le
ponemos, pues más complicado será de
de que nos lo de que nos de que nos lo
acepten, ¿no?
A este no está mal.
Bueno, hay precios de todos los colores,
pero bueno, por en esos entornos a
partir de aquí, mira, estes ahí 100 y
pico, ese 1560 y tantos, no sé, o sea,
depende depende de lo que vaya. Mira,
2000 W 100.
A ver, si hay muchos dispositivos,
evidentemente tendrá que tener más
capacidad. Al tener más capacidad
también debería de tener más capacidad
almacenaje, ¿no? Y durante cuánto tiempo
me puede ofrecer
ese un
electricidad mientras mientras hay un
apacón o hay un corte de luz o hay todas
esas cosas las tenemos que tener en
cuenta.
¿Vale? Los sistemas de alimentación
interrumpida corrigen todas las
deficiencias de la corriente eléctrica,
o sea, picos de tensión, etcétera. Es
decir, actúan de estabilizadores,
garantizan el fluido frente a cortes de
corriente, proporcionan el flujo
eléctrico adecuado.
Imaginar los aunque aquí se suelen poner
individuales, en esa sala de 100 m²,
imaginarla, todo llena de puestos de
trabajo y con, o sea, ahí, ¿qué
tendríamos?
Una solución a lo mejor es poner un side
cada tres equipos.
Otra solución es centralizarlo y poner
seis tochos que que
almacenen todo. O sea, eso ir, bueno, ya
lo veremos con diferentes ejercicios que
vayamos haciendo.
¿Vale? El SAON tiene en su interior unos
acumuladores que se cargan en el régimen
normal de funcionamiento en caso de
corte de corriente. Los acumuladores
producen la energía eléctrica que
permite los guardar los datos que
tuvieran abiertos las aplicaciones de
los usuarios y cerrar orden y cerrar
ordenadamente los sistemas operativos.
Si si además queremos no tener que
parar, hay que instalar grupos
electrógenos otros generadores de
corriente conectados a nuestra red
eléctrica. O sea, iría ahí iríamos ya
más allá, ¿vale? Hay un corte, el site
llega hasta donde llega por mucho que
nos gastemos en él, pero a partir de
determinado tiempo, determinada potencia
demandada, ya tendríamos que tirar de de
generadores eléctricos.
Generadores, ¿sabéis lo que es un
generador eléctrico, no?
Esto que hay en las obras, por ejemplo,
cuando están ahí abriendo una zanja,
tienen ahí eso funciona con es un motor
diesésel que está generando está
generando electricidad y hace un control
brutal o vais a una feria y lo mismo.
Vale, los servidores pueden a ver dónde
vamos que perd contiene, vale, estamos
aquí.
Vale, los servidores pueden comunicarse
con un SA a través de alguno de sus
puertos de comunicaciones, de modo que
el SA informa al servidor
de las incidencias que observa en la
corriente eléctrica. Windows, por
ejemplo, lleva ya preconfigurados una
lista de side de las principales
fabricantes con objeto facilitar lo más
posible la utilización de estos útiles
dispositivos. Otra necesidad muy
importante es una instalación
informática. En una instalación
informática es el control de la
temperatura y la humedad del ambiente
que se sitúan los ordenadores y otros
dispositivos de red. La regulación de
estos parámetros se realiza mediante la
instalación de aire acondicionado.
¿Qué es mejor para un para un equipo?
¿Que haya calor o que haya frío?
Frío,
¿vale?
La refrigeración es un es fundamental.
Vale, elementos de conectividad,
¿vale? Una vez que se tiene tendido el
cable en el edificio y que procede a
realizar las conexiones utilizando
conectores, rosetas, latuillas,
etcétera. Pat panel y latiguillos. Un
pass panel es un dispositivo de
interconexión a través del cual los
cables,
Espera, vamos a ponerlo.
fotos que no se ven muy bien.
Vale, a ver,
vale. Un Pass panel es un dispositivo de
interconexión a través del cual los
cables instalados se pueden conectar a
otros dispositivos de red o a otros
patch panel. Sobre un armario se
instalan patch panel que que se conectan
al cableado de la instalación de todo el
edificio y otros patch panel que se
conectan a los conectores de los
dispositivos de red. por ejemplo, los
hubs con montadores. Después una
multitud de latiguillos conectarán unos
patel con otros. De este modo el cambio
de config, o sea, por esto cobra
especiales,
importancia el el etiquetar, o sea, que
tengamos todo etiquetadísimo
y configurado por colores incluso.
Vale, después una multidon conectada
unos paranel con otros. De este modo, el
cambio de configuración de cableado se
realizará cambiando la conectividad del
latuillo sin tener que cambiar nada del
cableado largo ni las conexiones a los
dispositivos de red.
El cable largo instalado conectará las
rosetas con los pass panel. Las rosetas,
perdón,
las rosetas pueden adoptar multitud de
formas dependiendo del lugar en que se
fijen, canaleta, pared, etcétera, del
tipo de cable
a conectar y del conector que el usuario
utilizará.
La roseta presenta un conector por un
lado y una estructura de fijación de los
cables de pares por su reverso,
a la que serán crimpados.
Esto lo hicisteis el año pasado en
rosetas. Sí,
vale. Conexiones a rosetas RJ45. En
redes de área local sobre cables UTP
deben utilizarse conectores RJ45. Ahora
veremos el tema de lo de los cables que
es el siguiente. A ver.
cable. Vale, así está. Vale.
Eh, estos, eh, ¿dónde estamos?
Para este cable la red sol, ¿vale?
En redes de agrega local sobre cables
UTP deben utilizarse conectores RJ45.
De los cuatro pares del cable, la red
solo utilizará dos de ellos.
Los otros dos pueden utilizarse para
telefonía o alguna otra aplicación de
telecomunicaciones. ¿Vale? Esto lo
veremos. Estos cables se construyen de
acuerdo con la norma. Bueno, con la
norma esa. Los fabricantes de cables los
fabrican de acuerdo con un código de
colores que tiene que respetarse porque
el conector debe crimbarse de acuerdo
con este código. Vale, ahora eso lo
veremos. Es que no sé si hay ilustración
aquí de Vale, aquí lo tenemos. Vale,
si se observa una roseta por detrás,
descubriremos que tiene ocho pines.
A ver si hay aquí.
Sí, una buena foto de esto. Aquí no creo
que haya PC componentes. Roseta,
RJ
blanca, pero esta no tiene
es que esto no es.
Ah, vale, vale. Ahí tendríamos. Pero es
que se va a ver regulero esto.
¡Uf! Bueno, pues eso, pero es que se ve
mal
los colorcillos. Vale, tampoco estado
hablando de A ver, yo me refería más a
este tipo de rosetas que tenemos aquí en
la canaleta esta,
porque ahí no hay ninguna. Sí, pero es
que está A ver.
esta. Vamos aas
45 pared
del
sería la misma como se está viendo esta
de pared. A ver.
Vale, aquí por ejemplo
voy a darle a esta a ver.
Vale, aquí se ve bastante mejor.
Vale, en esos códigos de colores que se
ven en ta ta. ¿Dónde está?
Aquí se intuye. Vale,
no se ve bien.
Bueno, lo veremos porque abajo. Ahí,
¿verdad?
Rosetas de pared, Álvaro,
Vale, vale.
Vale,
est quizá. A ver, este, este igual está
mejor. A ver.
No, es que si solo tiene una imagen.
Vale, nada.
Vale,
si se observa una receta por detrás,
descubriremos que tiene ocho pines o
contactos. Algunas incorporen un pin más
para con una tierra y la protección del
cable. Cada filamiento de los cuatro
pares de de UTP de venir a uno de estos
contactos, ¿vale? Las estaciones
de la red se conectan a los dispositivos
de red a través de cables construidos
con el código de colores y, o sea, ahí
es que no hay si me equivoco, ¿vale? O
sea, vamos a a tiro hecho con los
colores y contactos de la tabla anterior
en ambos extremos. El cable se
confecciona de modo semejante a la
conexión a la roseta, aunque deberíamos
cambiar la herramienta que tendrá forma
de alig.
Vale. Hm. El conector RJ45,
los pines deben leerse con la pestaña
del conector hacia abajo, de modo que en
esta posición, o sea, lo tendremos en
cuenta todo ese tipo de de
recomendaciones, ¿vale? Cuando hagamos
la práctica,
¿vale? La asociación de contactos del
conector con los códigos de colores de
cable UTP cruzado sería la expresada en
la en la siguiente figura.
¿Vale? Aquí tenemos las dos normas y
aquí cómo sería el cruzado de esos
cables,
¿vale? que habíamos quedado eh para que
serve un cable cruzado.
O sea, porque en una instalación no
pondríamos un cable cruzado, ¿no? Una
una instalación no tendría sentido poner
un cable cruzado
o qué. En una instalación de imaginar
aquí,
aquí no lo pondríamos, ¿no?
Vale, eso solo lo queremos en
circunstancias especiales. Sería, mira,
esto es un cable. Ah, es que aquí sí que
tengo,
mira, fíjate,
tenemos que ponerlo así. Vale, mira,
mira los colores.
O sea, empezamos por
Ah, no te creas que yo que me ha dejado
la gaf.
Vale, sería el eh Vale, pues básicamente
lo que tenemos ahí de naranja a verde,
¿vale? Naranja, naranja con rayas, o
sea, de verde, el verde con rayas sería
huiría unido al naranja con rayas,
¿vale? Mira, echarle echarle un vistazo
así, ponerlo así y lo veréis.
Esa es la conexión correcta.
[Música]
Mientras que este
esto es un cable normal,
que los abre allá.
Vale, ahí tenemos todo en la misma
posición.
¿Ves? La diferencia
sí
empieza por blanco, raya
blanco, o sea, rayas blanco y naranja,
creo, porque no lo veo bien.
Sí,
sí. Luego viene el naranja.
exacto. Luego vendría el verde.
Espera. Sí, es el verde. Rayas verdes
rayas. Azul.
Azules rayas.
Vale, el día que hagamos práctica,
venimos con las gafas, los que nos hagan
falta.
Vale,
vale, etiquetado los cables y si queréis
pasamos ya con el, o sea, miramos esto y
nos pasamos al paquet tráer un poquito y
así vamos hacemos la clase así un
poquito más dinámica,
¿vale? etiquetado de los cables. La
norma tal especifica que cada
terminación, bueno, lo voy a decir ella
bar-606
especifica que cada terminación de
hardware debe tener alguna etiqueta que
lo identifique, ¿vale? Esto está
normalizado. Lo que pasa que esto es
como todo, que tengo prisa, que esto,
que lo otro, no lo etiqueto y mal.
Vale,
un cable tiene dos terminaciones, por
tanto, cada uno de estos extremos
recibirá un nombre. No es recomendable
la utilización de un sistema de
etiquetado con relación a un momento
concreto. Es mejor utilizar
nomenclaturas neutras. Por ejemplo, si
etiquetamos un PC como PC de dirección y
luego el lugar del edificio en donde se
ubica la dirección cambia, tendríamos
que cambiar también el etiquetado. Por
ello, se debe intentar que el etiquetado
sea fijo. Se recomienda la utilización
de etiquetas que incluyan un identific
un identificador de sala y un
identificador de conector. Así sabremos
todo sobre el cable, dónde empieza y
dónde acaba. Por ejemplo, podríamos
etiquetar un cable con el siguiente
identificador. ¿Vale? Pues
[Música]
este cable indicaría que está tendido
desde la roseta número dos de la sala 3
hasta la roseta 24 de la sala 5. ¿Vale?
Esto, claro, el ejemplo que nos ha
puesto es muy es muy correcto. Imaginar
que un departamento dirección estaba en
esa sala y de repente cambia y se lo
llevan a otra. Entonces, claro, ahí nos
perdemos un poco. Entonces, esta este
tipo de nomenaturas está mejor.
Las rosetas en las quizá no tan
esquemático, o sea, porque
Vale. Hm. Sí que está normalizado y tal,
pero a lo mejor un poquito más de
un poquito más de leyenda no está no
está de más, depende de lo que nos
quepa.
Vale, las rosetas en las salas 3 y 5
irían etiquetadas con 0302
y 05Rs24.
Vale,
vale. Pues si queréis lo dejamos hasta
aquí.
Y vamos a vamos con el packer.
A ver que esto me voy a descargar
un datos.
Esto está aquí. Vale, os voy a subir
al drive el los ejercicios de de Cisco,
¿vale? Y si queréis, pues eso, vamos
haciéndolos,
¿vale? Ayer nos quedamos en el tres,
¿no? Ejercicio número tres. Ahora
pasaríamos al cuatro.
A ver.
Esto es
vale de cuentas
aquí.
Vale. E
unidad ahora lo lo estoy subiendo.
Vale. Reyes locales.
Regas no valuables. No, entregas noos.
Vale.
Eh, vale. Voy a poner ahí.
Vale, ahí lo tenéis.
A ver, si queréis, pues vamos haciéndolo
y si nos surgen dudas
miramos a ver qué
a ver voy a guardarme donde nos hemos
quedado con este con el temario.
Hm hm.
Vale. ¿Qué tal lo lleváis?
¿Cuántos packets trer hicisteis el año
pasado?
500.
El paqueto.
Sí,
pero lo llevas mejor ahora o qué?
ese aspecto el ladrillo bien.
No es muy amigable, pero bueno,
es lo que lo que hay.
Bueno, sería
tenéis algún lo habéis hecho alguno lo
habéis acabado
Ha.
El ejercicio 3 no llega switch, ¿verdad?
Se implementa ahora.
Voy a hacerlo yo también.
genérico sería este de aquí.
Diferencias entre este y este.
Este digamos que sería Este sería de 24
también. A ver,
a ver.
Estos son
dos
6 24,
¿vale? Y este tiene 24 también, pero
solo tiene, a ver, esta conexión que es
a consola, mientras que este otro
lo que tiene eso.
Va a ser gigabit. A ver,
a ver, configuración.
Vale, vale. Sí. Gigabit de Ethernet
una y dos.
Sería este de aquí, este a consola y
este es el genérico.
Y este es más genérico todavía. Switch 1
y switch.
Spech
[Música]
es que como cambió la versión
¿Qué va?
Este está vacío. Este está para que le
pongamos los módulos.
Genial.
[Música]
Vale, respecto a
esto, hacer las acabar el ejercicio e ir
enviándolo
al al drive. Vale,
acordaos vuestro nombre y el vuestro
nombre barra baja apellidos barra baja,
el nombre del ejercicio y si tenéis que
enviar más
un par de archivos en en vez de uno
porque habéis querido hacer una una
descripción de los pasos realizados, que
no es el caso, ¿vale?
pues pues enviáis un archivo comprimido,
¿vale? Y esto junto con los
con los con los que hay ya puestos y
luego estaba el evaluable también,
¿verdad? Evaluable en redes creo que sí
que lo habíamos puesto. Vale, pues darlo
en cuenta ya para
para los tiempos. En la plataforma de
Tam de Tamet tendréis a mano derecha en
vuestro usuario os vienen las
actividades próximas a entregar, ¿vale?
Os viene el recordatorio de todo.
Vale, pues voy a cerrar esto.